[inaudible] dot.
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] bar table materium component.
Yo [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] high tech could
Keanjay Internet [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah.
Yes.
That's how I got
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it.
That's how he got [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
and I'm your [inaudible].
We don't, I said, well, could it so
shame? Yeah. Ah, yeah. Your tacos too.
You don't want to call you
[inaudible] [inaudible] then there
could there sync up with that.
She gained [inaudible] Yoga.
You eat.
I get [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and said,
I'm the Danes.
[inaudible] go [inaudible] hang out.
What? We have one more production is hard
and it has ar. Vr means that I'm earning
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] in
gains a do gooder or done in
the cable. We punctured
[inaudible] Kazanjian Oh God, yeah.
[inaudible] in [inaudible] or [inaudible]
his soul creates a need to create a
prompt.
[inaudible].
Those actually are pumped
it out of [inaudible] data.
[inaudible] going to data points.
Okay,
so more young 100 off. You don't
got to [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
harpooning gains. It's,
he got beat up when you go and bore
and Ian Pangeum dork hurricanes or data
pilots.
How Todo Man [inaudible] is a case
or to him he [inaudible] get that and
engaging [inaudible] call critical
[inaudible] we didn't have [inaudible].
Okay.
Can you say or provided that young man
in the crowd up when you came to town at
[inaudible]? We should put in
there. And you got my para.
You don't show me mean to you
get [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Pega
Najam they will nature chip side.
You can put tiger in and they're tiny.
Uh, well, heightened peg on there.
Now I get A's.
So was how I shoot and [inaudible]
clean [inaudible] peso claim or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] in the
states. It's yoga. Good Texas Julian.
And they're calling an
attic doors. Hi, I'm
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] or Myanmar. Uh,
cause also among kids hanging on you
could kill them and you can tell by
[inaudible] in graduating goes had hub.
We are in and day [inaudible] texts
us to leave. They have campus junior,
so criminal justice got it.
And we should meet then and could I
need to campus [inaudible] so called
[inaudible] [inaudible]
forensic psychology phd wise
only in then Cronin's Kim
Potts says [inaudible] [inaudible]
so [inaudible] should and could,
they would tell them [inaudible] either
care, putting in, get what I get ya,
Eh, Tony and cigarettes
and determines that the TV,
I said it's how he got TV luminary
we'd get them were near to God is on
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a day,
which it could to gay.
She go with in intimacy
hadn't gone and bore propelling it. And
in your words are technical palms area.
It's at the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] the
Lord and she got [inaudible] account.
Terry Manuso, Eh, crooked Damon Age.
It's, what can I get? That's him.
Yong Kim Todd and saw dictate her hand,
you know, an 80 gig appropriate law.
It'll keep that indicates a pulsar guy.
Go
[inaudible] [inaudible] and there
are millions on same DDA. Sorry.
[inaudible] oh, you don't
want new? Yay. Cool.
It'll ban come CQA icon the palm.
Jenna's hydrometer [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] sewing equal or
done palm Jay [inaudible] one answer.
I'm the range of [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] pink base.
Such a crooked [inaudible] Damien
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
more suck on Palestinian.
Took it and get with Tom [inaudible].
Tom
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] to [inaudible].
Daniel,
do you go into [inaudible]?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Ben, Tom and not done palm. Jason earn a
[inaudible] [inaudible] a tire.
Uh, the, uh, poor Nika,
Nika and [inaudible] died and got her
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] I got to go in and say
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
Yoda propilot the opposite side.
[inaudible] there are
Chitra Roman newborns.
Herringbone, you know, so
crazily inner critic who suck.
How a woman [inaudible].
I go more [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and they called
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] well,
it's helpful. Yeah. Sorry.
A [inaudible] man.
[inaudible] and I'm [inaudible] you go to
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] you don't think I got
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] and their [inaudible].
Ah,
[inaudible] [inaudible] I could
go on and be Google Khaki.
Tanya Kresser in Gi. You
get compensation? Yeah,
I get on and got her head or you get
more damage here. She got and took her on
[inaudible] [inaudible] told me
10 years. [inaudible] el Maro
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] means
[inaudible] wore pants are born young
again, the woman and so on. Tom,
we can get into the teacher.
My hear this and I are being controlled
when Gaga and war [inaudible] was
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] we'll learn as a
[inaudible] [inaudible] hunted
scenario here. We did not,
and then get comedy more
with regard [inaudible].
The aim was some data and
kindle punk wrongful goes,
I can just get one of them does.
When you started or [inaudible]
Antonio [inaudible] more
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] videos
and you get them in a [inaudible].
We did not.
And then Amedee war Peter [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] has had
children or some young into a tall,
but I only get 10 yoga. Uh,
she goes, well, you don't,
you're [inaudible],
eh,
seeking advice insertion and gay
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Oh,
[inaudible]
magic.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] in July.
Janko
[inaudible] [inaudible] body.
So Gay
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] would have his ankle yards or
patient menudo crooked Tammany.
You're going to have the down
times when your tongue tie.
He had been Jeca and eco.
And what do you got or terrible.
[inaudible] then you go to,
again,
we'll knock on the [inaudible]
or [inaudible] Ohio boar hunting.
Uh, yeah. Cron in jail time. Another
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
more [inaudible] you know,
there are some, and then some
take it on and get to Jersey.
[inaudible] hard to kind of noisy.
We'll learn [inaudible] Florida.
Cheer a tongue kind argued in general
case. Go get them an edge tonight.
[inaudible] to remove the ship.
[inaudible] na [inaudible] kind of a more,
uh,
check [inaudible] energy
in general under Maddie.
Joke on the container. So we'll go
ahead and go around I and go round.
Could you go into upper int? Eh, I won't,
will [inaudible] to learn. Go ahead and
you can, Jay couldn't tell you guys.
So I'm a door wall.
Tom [inaudible] just
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] come down. It
would touch at noon. Yeah. Uh,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] Yoga Sutra
head or [inaudible]K and g
Yogi has Justin and there
couldn't dare, she got mad as you
were saying. Okay. Well Myan Ah, cool.
That's from Ghana is on tech.
Come there.
[inaudible]
just has her younger daughter.
How to do in jail.
[inaudible] [inaudible] that wasn't
going to gear tootsie man could,
they could [inaudible]
coating is such a weird name.
Id All your socket ideology. Jasmine,
they'll put them in question,
how was written there?
I did it in an Ahmad or we are my
sister and nutrition and gone earns.
How should I do the nutrition and grand
[inaudible] there you guys had allergies
and in she's actually could.
There was,
and then it's actually going
to change on [inaudible] eh?
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Tanya,
it's tidy up from [inaudible].
Shots are well take off. Generally.
We'll teach you senior year tank.
Well,
Todd or [inaudible] tagging Puerto
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
or [inaudible] secret door.
Oh. Carranza integrity hacky retarded.
Well, you get killed on the job,
eh?
They could sneak
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
in car psychopaths.
Saran and [inaudible] and Tom
was psychopaths or sociopaths.
[inaudible].
There's [inaudible] now a war sociopath.
[inaudible] legal officers
to though he's so social.
PESTA learn. Yeah. And that is it on
your whales? [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
it came to production.
[inaudible] [inaudible] man.
Antisocial personality disorder.
Rodeo panties or [inaudible] or
the hand taught terminology. Social
[inaudible] [inaudible] Yo,
antisocial personality soda. Critical
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a antisocial
personality disorder.
[inaudible] Tisch percent-ers a
hand Bannerman patch support center.
We did not an a, it's a boy.
John, can we answer under
[inaudible] [inaudible] she
puts until you can paddle,
call each of them. Just they
don't know. Get them in a cog in a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Sasha managing me
actually at the recruiter has her door.
Cause you guys have the TN side.
Amita [inaudible] star
and I'm going there cause
[inaudible] [inaudible]
mom would take him out. Go.
But [inaudible] is to delete the man.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
is a [inaudible] or [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and they
all just opinion Sadia to Linda
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] and then Karen
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Yogi
[inaudible] [inaudible] could get my
Nigga isn't song.
You don't be on [inaudible]
chrome session bodies.
Who can do it? I activation
tangle. Yeah. And they get,
you told me you were trying to
get it to me or you're talking
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
and their [inaudible] journey.
Vob. They get them and they pollute
campaign again. I don't want to say, yeah,
you don't. I didn't get
home. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] activation, you know.
Well, hey, play activation.
You were more anxiety there.
You're either activation.
Yeah,
and you don't [inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] careful attention.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] activation.
Eat donuts and then go to a crooked,
terminate and say, you don't know.
Don't teach him or
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
had done months was on total is,
it's a Panto. Tastes are Palm J. Dot.
R [inaudible] and David [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
more younger daughter.
M bovine the, yeah, but white
collar psychopaths in car.
[inaudible] can we go again more?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] in jail.
It's how he's [inaudible] Eh,
good.
All the Yogis.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] 10 going on.
You take going.
Okay.
You're one.
I was in bar [inaudible] care to Gerald
Hannon Tbms and talk show I think you
think are so palm and Jay
[inaudible] to [inaudible].
Uh,
she got day awkward.
Hadn't had [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] you don't
turn psycho owner Shingo bought on
Pennsylvania to be,
I want to buy entity second and their
[inaudible] we're going out and they're
cause [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
doctor [inaudible] so
[inaudible] [inaudible] and then we'll
go one or [inaudible] Tom at home at all.
I
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and they get their
currency in Calgary.
Could the hitcher yeah.
Could Tabula Rasa to cause new TV
or [inaudible] but attack come you,
she called. Yeah. I just got the
tone to take. I take, I took it.
That was in a herd as long as
[inaudible] it's a fixed on,
I was talking to was all
by any coming at eight
charm or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] he had
an injector
[inaudible] [inaudible] we did not.
I saw [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] how do you
know too? When she told you and said,
[inaudible] you don't
tell him, didn't he? Me?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
chromium and Sasha buggy come and he says,
I endomondo [inaudible] and
[inaudible] because I am
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] you didn't put
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I'm thinking that
opens her Amira. Tom
[inaudible], Eh, cookie generic
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] to loops and I,
or can they do in terms of
a population is so they can,
they're
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
or [inaudible] going again over
[inaudible] [inaudible] to go.
[inaudible] rituximab kicked
him and then he won't get up.
Go home or DNA.
[inaudible] [inaudible] bassoon.
More, uh, TBMs and talk.
Show is, oh, I can turn
on his own. Uh, uh,
I [inaudible] so what
can I [inaudible] again?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Daddy.
I got [inaudible] hockey.
Either I putting other queer
pain and either you in or hit
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] was intentional
bicycle. Now we'll go around the table,
but it's a vagina.
So I think I ain't there.
You get [inaudible] Oh,
[inaudible] Tom Tattoo me.
Sundin there.
[inaudible] you can wear Manzoni Pale.
She was here.
Get them when they can and we [inaudible]
I get them on their porch and we don't
compare. And then you're looking
to hit on the jet and then go home.
Come could Amiel together and then, yeah.
Could that many int eh that end hotels,
orangutan and
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] you can just
use your hand away or two that says
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible]. [inaudible] yeah, that shit.
[inaudible] Danika pennants
from jump loan and they're
[inaudible] [inaudible] could I just,
she hadn't tear he, I just, you, she pays
or could you be either, I will catch you.
[inaudible] me.
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah.
Yeah.
I just see a gay being
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] oh yeah,
just she got,
which is why it's [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hassle. Oh yeah, you got, okay,
so pennant from jump low or take
a 10 old good spent two hours ago.
Go [inaudible] go to get in each.
We put
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] in the yard gains,
Eh,
table one is, oh, well.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and [inaudible]
and [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] auto loans.
I should.
And [inaudible] in the [inaudible] yoga
tongue change and band Tommy [inaudible]
go Tommy. Yeah, just she, wow. Can't
get rid of [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
uh, I hung young gay, Gay,
uh, crack. I said, well, Nah, I mean, uh,
we [inaudible] and you go,
you're going to go,
you get a handout and you go,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] Ohio in say,
Uj Guy. He took the children would, would
tell you don't need to pack your audit.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] ammonia.
Yeah. Jessica. Yeah.
You were to go to [inaudible].
Uh, he, I got [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
or [inaudible] collided.
Remind again [inaudible]
table and hit that.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Lucas, I should teach you, Eh,
eh. Come on down. When she
told him underdog. I do.
[inaudible] once I run in kitchens had
taken that up when you got [inaudible]
because it's about guilty
tolerance.
How I got to [inaudible] who is
from gay [inaudible] she said
[inaudible] [inaudible] was just
thinking get homework. Qatar.
I was in [inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible] or [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] of the [inaudible]
and [inaudible] he should take on as
a [inaudible] process.
You mean the product's got now I own cause
it mattered. Tom Did or hard. They put
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] God
says I want Jaggy and Nadine and they're
doing
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] this was her answer.
I'm a depot or American target targets.
So [inaudible] there,
they hadn't paid [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] being [inaudible] spike on
now we'll get you [inaudible] sneak
a great guy and check Chris. Okay?
Are we going to tell you that she gets a
[inaudible] [inaudible] and their
currency goes how she ran into a
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
okay.
Until I got to Aa and [inaudible]
day for not a profile on [inaudible].
They tell us, hey, I got
[inaudible] get him, man. Eh,
well propilot 300 Tacloban
a European did is horrible.
She imagine teaching team Jackie tickets,
man Bannon freerunner cougar patsy
man sometimes [inaudible] cricket,
Eh,
uh,
[inaudible] around then improving the
regards he acquired or [inaudible] or
[inaudible]. [inaudible] man, it's
like the owner own. You learn.
So she didn't Indonesia
[inaudible] he couldn't talk.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] you
know me and then we'll learn [inaudible]
activation or [inaudible] man,
corona I
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] so Anita,
you change up.
Who you [inaudible] or
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
then there Trishy got the woman,
I good treasure the tongue.
So hand and got [inaudible] to go.
[inaudible] blonde.
Who doctor taking manner we did not an m
forgot which man could move in a day as
a project taking [inaudible],
the
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
[inaudible] man, their conduct clinic,
the Upper Manheim,
Yan Carmelo once and then [inaudible]
chattel and your medicare AI guys.
We aren't Chobani magazine and [inaudible]
crazy icon there out again it cattle
seek and NGA cause actually
[inaudible] man ual intentional things,
high needs that corner you by
Haggai, Mandan Quran, Kweyama law,
more Paleo Freehand.
You run program and taking off Nigga
[inaudible] where the tutors Mandan
incubator take, go ahead and
go. Shit could get hearing aids.
Hired was a project there then in
queens in a terrible get cause.
Then goddamn turned around and he saw
eh engineered and do the evaluation and
they come in now don't turn it on that.
That's how they get kind of
[inaudible] in your town and day.
[inaudible] I said, well you don't know.
Was he bent asset to the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] to
[inaudible] tire where the other,
and while there are
boundaries,
I demand it should be Montgomery.
He gets home technologies that
are there. Like I said, well,
I didn't know [inaudible] to
Ken Cock journey and then,
and there that and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
heighten a pretty good
[inaudible] on Monday.
Uh,
[inaudible] soil,
eh?
[inaudible]
yeah.
[inaudible] oh.
Oh, it's okay. Cause
then he gets a tech, uh,
Tainan buttons.
[inaudible]
good.
[inaudible] game.
Tom Jones. How are you
guys? [inaudible] me Sunday.
[inaudible] I talked
to the [inaudible] hey,
[inaudible] z.
Hey,
could you say [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
uh,
problem.
Jay [inaudible] or [inaudible]
should have told me you got an NBA.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
we did not [inaudible] soil
and the beg in that end of [inaudible].
Annandale.
We're granja Kiesewetter
tons of other job done. Go to
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] TB or Pema.
You don't get that. She wanted
us, her children and they,
oh [inaudible] they can now come
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] on high tech.
[inaudible] [inaudible] and others in,
in Palm.
Just figgy Kango term critical to
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] you were saying then testing
Aba.
Nah.
Oh nine or 29 to [inaudible] to keen to
Tony or someone Sontag or how she said
how many job?
What are you going to be on my dad?
You're going to have
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
I didn't could equal, no, we didn't.
How a yeah,
man.
And then dom testing upturn cause I
didn't have [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
can young boar. I'm going to take
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah,
I eat [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
has mentioned him. Comes up
Chris.
Sale.
You're done.
Bob [inaudible] go back to and gutsy.
Patricia
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] journey. Uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and
the Keenan [inaudible] couldn't do what
do y'all get them on there?
We got to Cologne.
Could gave her door was
[inaudible] Chang is here.
Well done today, Megan. And
we'll come back. [inaudible] eh,
that's him.
I go to Tim [inaudible].
Yeah,
of course.
I got to take a chunk of one day.
They'll go there for
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Yup. Keenan [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] cats eat.
I wasn't gonna cut and [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] told me
Huggies or energy research in the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] don't have the
comes out and the mill, for example,
cancer.